To improve performance, clients often cache
parts of a webpage. Caching can occur
in multiple places. Your browser can cache
some objects locally on your very machine.
Caches can also be deployed in the network. Sometimes your local ISP may
have a web cache, and later we'll also look at how content distribution networks
are a special type of webcast that can be used to improve performance. To see
how caching can improve performance, consider the case
where the origin web server, may host the
content for a particular website, but it's particularly
far away. Now, we already know that TCP
throughput is inversely proportional to round-trip times. So,
the further away that this web content is,
the slower the web page will load, both
because latency is bigger, and because throughput is
lower. If, instead, the client could fetch content
from the local cache, performance could be drastically improved,
by fetching content from a more nearby location.
Caching can also improve the performance when multiple
clients are requesting the same content. In this
case, not only do all of the local clients
benefit from the content being cached locally. But
the ISP also saves costs on transit, because
it doesn't have to pay to keep transferring
the same content over these expensive links. Instead,
it can simply serve the content to the
clients locally. To ensure that clients are seeing
the most recent version of a page, caches
periodically expire content, based on the expire setter
that we already saw. Caches can also check
with the origin server to see whether the
original content has been modified. If the content
has not been modified, the origin server would
respond to a cache check request with a
304 or a not modified response. Clients can
be directed to a cache in multiple ways.
One is with browser configuration. So you can open
your browser and explicitly configure the browser
to point to a local cache so that
all HTTP requests first are directed to the
local cache, before the request is forwarded to
the origin. In the second approach, the
origin server or the service hosting the content,
might actually direct your browser to a cache.
This can be done with a special reply
to a DNS request. We can see these effects,
for example, when we do a DNS look up
for Google.com. The response returns a number of IP
addresses and when I ping the IP address, we
see that the resulting IP address is only one
millisecond away. Which indicates that that server is, not
far away, but is in fact, very likely on
a local network, probably even, the Georgia Tech campus
network, in this case.